Bitte schön.
Okay.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte mich kurz vorstellen. Mein Name ist Rahmikut.
Ich bin der Diensthabender auf der Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, klar. Hauptsache irgendjemand hilft mir.
Ja, natürlich.
Tafiana bin ich da.
Okay, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Anna Kowalski.
Anna?
Kowalski.
Okay.
Anna mit Doppeln, oder?
Anna mit Doppeln, ja.
Okay.
Würden Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen langsam bestabieren?
Ja, der ist auch schwierig. Geh mich zu.
K-U-W-A-L-S-K-I.
Okay, gut.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin noch 67 Jahre alt.
67 Jahre alt?
Okay, könnten Sie bitte ihr Gebustatum ...
Ja, das ist der 9.7054.
9.701934.
Okay, danke.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ja, so.
7980 kg.
70 kg?
70 kg, okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen, Frau Kowalski.
Welche Beschwerden führen Sie hierher?
Was ist passiert?
Ja, ich habe solche Bauchschmerzen.
Es ist immer schlimmer geworden.
Das hat schon ein paar Tage angefangen.
Jetzt sind die Schmerzen aber wirklich heftig.
Was mir tatsächlich ein bisschen unheimlich ist,
ich habe mich zweimal übergeben müssen.
Da war Blut in dem Erbrochenen drin.
Das kam mir jetzt nun ganz komisch vor.
Ja, ich verstehe, Herr Kowalski.
Das sieht sehr heftig aus.
Sie haben Bauchschmerzen.
Ja, im Oberbauch sind die Schmerzen.
Die werden immer schlimmer.
Ich verstehe.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie stechend?
Nee, eher so dumpf.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sie haben sich zweimal übergeben.
Ja, richtig.
Ja, und wann war das?
Das einmal war gestern und vorgestern.
Und tatsächlich war das so,
dass die Schmerzen dann, nachdem ich mich übergeben musste,
da waren die Schmerzen ein bisschen besser.
Aber ansonsten sind die wirklich ziemlich doll die Schmerzen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Die Schmerzen sind immer da.
Ja, die sind nicht sehr gegangen, oder?
Ganz weggegangen sind die, die sind ein bisschen besser geworden.
Aber sobald ich versuche, etwas zu essen,
wird es wieder ganz schlimm mit den Schmerzen.
Ja, für mich, wie ich denke, sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
von 1 bis 10, wobei eines sehr leicht und 10 sehr starken
Schmerzen entspricht.
Ach, also bestimmt über die Hälfte.
Ich würde mal sagen, bei 7 sind die vielleicht.
Am Anfang war die Schmerzintensität 7.
Aber nachdem übergeben, also sind sie auch 7.
Da waren sie vielleicht ein bisschen weniger,
dann vielleicht bei 6 oder 5.
Aber sobald ich etwas esse oder versuche, was zu essen,
ja, jetzt habe ich gedacht, ich muss doch mal hier zu Ihnen kommen.
Okay, obbauchschmerzen, Sie haben mir gesagt.
Also das ist die Seite oder linksseite?
Nein, das ist eigentlich in der Schmerzintensität 7.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperegion
ausstrahlen?
Okay, ich höre Sie.
Ja, ich meine, ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Schmerzen in eine
andere Körperegion ausstrahlen?
Also, wieso?
Nein, das ist nur da im Oberbau, sonst eigentlich nirgendwo.
Okay, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Überkeit?
Ja, klar, ja.
Auch Überkeit.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Sind Ihnen schwindelig oder?
Ob mir schwindelig ist?
Ja.
Nee, das habe ich nicht.
Ich fühle mich nur so ein bisschen schlapp eigentlich,
seit ein paar Tagen.
Seit ein paar Tagen.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie so enlihe Beschwerden davor bemerkt
oder ist das erst mal aufgeblieben?
Das habe ich noch nie so gehabt.
Nee, das ist, glaube ich, ja, das ist das erste Mal.
Ja, ich kann mich nicht erinnern,
dass ich mich schon mal so gefühlt habe.
Okay, haben Sie saures Aufstoßen oder?
Nee, also, wenn dann eben diese richtige
Übelkeit mit übergeben, aber saure Aufstoßen
eigentlich so normalerweise nicht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Yukaris oder haben Sie
gebliehere Veränderung der Haut
oder am Augen bemerkt?
Da ist mir nichts aufgefallen, nein.
Okay, okay, gut.
Und möchtet ihr noch etwas erinnern?
Nein, ich möchte noch etwas erinnern.
Ergenstn oder das alles?
Ja, also, was mir noch aufgefallen ist,
ich habe halt so noch Rheuma entkrankt.
Was ist das?
Geriassana, nein, ich weiß nicht.
Geriassana, nein.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht.
Hallo, machen Sie mal eben, ja, danke.
Ich habe wegen Rheuma nämlich halt Cortison.
Und jetzt habe ich in den letzten Wochen
2-3 kg zugenommen, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Also 2-3 kg haben Sie abgenommen?
Nee, zugenommen.
Zugenommen, also entschuldigt.
Ja, ja, ja.
Seit 2-3 Wochen?
Ja, in den letzten 4 Wochen würde ich sagen.
Ich nehme halt Cortison wegen des Rheumars.
Okay, Cortison Tabletten, oder?
Ja.
Okay, wer hat das?
Oh, versteht ihr da drauf?
Ich muss mal auf meinen Zügel gucken, einen Augenblick.
Das ist Prätnisolon 15 Milligramm, nämlich zurzeit morgens eine.
Prätnisolon 15 Milligramm.
Organs.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Rheumatoids-Patriots?
Oh, das habe ich schon eine ganz lange, über 10 Jahre schon.
Ja, das ist eine sehr große Art.
Das habe ich schon eine ganz lange, über 10 Jahre schon.
Über 10 Jahre?
Okay, okay, ich verstehe.
Und das, also, hielt die Tabletten einen oder wie gehen Sie damit um?
Ja, manchmal muss ich auch noch Schmerztabletten nehmen.
Aber wir versuchen halt, es irgendwie damit in den Griff zu kriegen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Welche Tabletten nehmen Sie?
Ich nehme sie, ne?
Okay, okay.
Aber wenig eigentlich.
Welche Dosierung?
50 Milligramm, eine dreimal am Tag.
Dreimal am Tag?
Morgens, mittags und abends.
Okay, regelmäßig nehmen Sie einen, oder?
Ja, wenn es mir ganz gut geht, lasse ich die auch mal weg, aber normalerweise.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Okay, auch nehmen Sie als Magenschutz ein Medikamente.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich an Magenschutz nehme, ich nehme nichts.
Nee, okay, okay, gut.
Ja, haben Sie Probleme, einem da durchzuschlafen, Frau Kuaski?
Ja, jetzt in letzter Zeit, weil es mir jetzt nicht so gut geht,
schlafe ich schon nicht gut und ich schwitze auch ein bisschen in der Nacht.
Schweitzen in der Nacht, seit wann?
Seit 14 Tagen, ja, seit 14 Tagen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich auch erst jetzt in letzter Zeit gewesen.
Aber ich sage auch, es geht mir gerade so gar nicht gut, deswegen bin ich auch gekommen.
Okay, okay, also, aber das Medik mit diese Beschwerden, seit ein paar Tagen
oder seit einem Monat, schwitzen Sie?
Nee, das mit dem Schwitzen ist vielleicht so seit 14 Tagen oder so.
Okay, seit 14 Tagen müssen Ihr Unterwäsche wechseln, oder?
Ja, so, je nachdem, wenn ich aufwache, muss ich holen,
mal das Nachttent ausziehen und etwas anderes anziehen.
Aber manchmal merke ich das auch erst morgens, dann wenn ich aufstehe,
dass ich geschwitzt habe.
Okay, manchmal brauchen Sie Unterwäsche zu wechseln.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, haben Sie Fieber oder Stelfrost?
Das ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Okay, verstehe.
Okay, und ja, Sie schlafen nicht gut.
Also, das hat…
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchschlafen besonders?
Was können Sie sagen?
Na ja, also, jetzt zur Zeit wegen dieser komischen Bauchschmerzen
habe ich halt insgesamt auch zum Einschlafen Schwierigkeiten.
Normalerweise kann ich wohl einschlafen,
aber wacht dann irgendwann unterwegs auf.
Okay.
Also durchschlafen Sie?
Ich verstehe, aber seit ein paar Tagen haben Sie Einschlafen,
ich verstehe.
Okay, okay, gut.
Okay, und ja, wie sieht Ihr appatit aus?
Also, wissen Sie gut, oder?
Normalerweise schon, aber jetzt eben zur Zeit macht das Essen überhaupt keinen Spaß,
weil ich jedes Mal Schmerzen habe, wenn ich etwas gegessen habe.
Okay, okay.
Und jetzt habe ich eigentlich auch schon die letzten Tage nur noch so versucht,
so ganz vorsichtig, auch gekochtes Zeug zu essen und nichts Kaltes und nix Heises,
sondern alles nur so schlabberkram, aber trotzdem tut das weh.
Okay, okay, ja.
Ja, das ist sehr schlimm, ich kann gut verstehen, Frau Koski.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Romatoid-Artist haben Leidl,
andere Vorerkrankungen, Diabetes oder Blutdruck.
Ja, ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe ich auch noch.
Blutdruck, okay.
Dann haben Sie Blutdruck.
Bitte?
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Das ist auch schon über zehn Jahre.
Auch über zehn Jahre.
Okay.
Wie stellt denn Blutdruck ein?
Also nehmen Sie irgendwelche...
Dann nehme ich Kapto-Pril.
Kapto-Pril.
Okay, Kapto-Pril.
Okay, verstehe.
Werler-Dosierung nehmen Sie ein?
Ja, ich meine, da steht 25 drauf.
Okay, wie oft?
Eine morgens, eine abends.
Okay, gut.
Noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Oder sind Sie schon mal operiert worden, Frau Koski?
Ja, also, da war ich ganz jung, da war ich 18.
Da habe ich mal einen Kreuzband-Riss gehabt.
Da bin ich operiert worden.
Aber sonst, zum Glück, keine Operation bisher.
Okay, okay.
Und welche Seite war das?
Also, rechts Seite oder links?
Rechts.
Rechts Seite.
Aber aktuell haben Sie keine Probleme mit Kreuzband-Riss.
Mit den Beinen? Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, okay, gut.
Sehr gut.
Und noch andere Operationen?
Sie haben keine OP.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Korzontabletten,
also Prätnisolone,
Mikrofenac, so wie Kapto-Pril einziehen.
Noch andere Medikamente?
Also, das ist alles.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ja, ich habe nicht mehr Fragen.
Haben Sie irgendeine Allergien,
ich meine Polen oder Antibiotika, zum Beispiel?
Nein.
Zum Beispiel, bekommen Sie Beleihungen,
wenn Sie Brot oder Milchprodukte essen?
Nein, so etwas kann ich alles gut vertragen.
Alles ist gut.
Okay, sehr gut.
Können Sie mir sagen, Frau Koaski, ob Sie rauchen?
Ja, ich rauche seit 20 Jahren.
Rauch ich bestimmt fast ein Päckchen am Tag.
Ein Päckchen?
Ja.
Okay, seit 20 Jahren ein Päckchen.
Wie viele Zigaretten sind in einer Schakke?
20, 20.
Okay.
Aber davor haben Sie nicht geraucht, nur seit 20 Jahren.
Nein, ich habe das irgendwie so spät angefangen.
Okay, okay, verstehe.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Bier, Wein, oder?
Ja, Glas Wein tricke ich schon ein paar Mal in der Woche.
Ja.
Ein Wein.
Ein Glas Wein, ja.
Ein Glas Wein, Provo.
Nein, ein paar Mal in der Woche.
Ein paar Mal in der Woche.
Ich gehe nach dem, was so los ist.
Okay, okay.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Okay, das passt.
Und ja, nächste Frage ist Routine Frage.
Frau Koaski, konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein, so etwas mache ich nicht.
Nein, das ist keine Verwirrung.
Okay, ja, ich bin, ich gesagt habe, ist das nur Routine Frage.
Okay?
Nehmen Sie sich nicht per se.
Per se.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Hausfrau gewesen, ja, soweit, ich bin natürlich immer noch Hausfrau.
Ich bin ja jetzt im Rentenalter.
Aber ich habe nie außerhalb von Haus gearbeitet.
Okay, Sie sind eine Hausfrau.
Aber Sie bestimmen der Arbeit.
Okay, verstehe.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Okay, gut.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, gut, die sind natürlich jetzt schon erwachsen, ne?
Erwachsen, okay.
Ja, die sind ja schon groß, ja.
Okay.
Okay, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Zwei.
Zwei Kinder.
Ich habe sogar schon Enkelkinder.
Ach so, ein Enkelkind.
Zwei Enkelkinder habe ich schon.
Zwei Enkelkind, okay.
Und zwei Kinder, das ist gut, ja.
Sind ihr Kinder auch ihr Enkelkind gesund?
Ja, die sind alle gesund.
Okay, sehr gut.
Ja, das freut mich.
Ja, in Bezug auf Hamid Anamnese.
Er ist eher älter noch.
Oh nein, mein Vater ist am Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Und meine Mutter, die ist sehr alt geworden.
Aber weiß gar nicht, die hatte glaube ich keine richtig schlimme Erkrankung.
Also keine chronische Erkrankung.
Okay, ja, Mutter hat keine chronische Erkrankung oder sie hat nicht operiert worden.
Nicht, dass ich das nöpfe.
Okay, wann ist ihr Vater gestorben?
Oh, das ist auch schon wieder eine Weile her.
Der ist nicht so alt geworden.
Der ist mit 79 gestorben.
Und meine Mutter ist 88 geworden.
Okay, ihr Mutter lebt noch mit 80?
Nein, die lebt nicht mehr.
Ah, ihr Mutter auch nicht.
Ja, aber die hatte irgendwie keine, die so ein Altersstrecke gestorben.
Die hatte keine grundlegende Erkrankung.
Ach so, alt ist schwer, okay.
Aber sie wüsste nicht, welche Erkrankung.
Ne, weiß nicht, woran die tatsächlich gestorben ist.
Sie war einfach alt, ne?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Ja, es fühlt sich so an, als würde ein Teil von ihnen fehlen.
Ja, so von der Geschichte fehlt das.
Da ist mit einmal so der Schnitt.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Okay, und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch Geschwister, ja.
Okay, sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind, ja, doch so weit sind die alle gesund, ja.
Okay, wie viele Geschwister haben Sie?
Zwei.
Zwei Geschwister, okay, alles ist gesund.
Ja, gut.
Okay, okay, Frau Kowalski.
Ja, vielen Dank für alle Informationen.
Ich habe vorerst alle für mich wichtigeren Fragen gestellt, okay.
Möchten Sie noch etwas ergänzen oder haben Sie irgendwelche Fragen?
Ja, was meinen Sie denn?
Wo kommen denn jetzt diese Schmerzen her?
Ja, ich verstehe ganz genau.
Was kann man dagegen machen?
Ja, ich verstehe ganz genau, dass Sie die eher beschwerden,
möglichst channelwissen möchten.
Aber ich würde sagen, dass wir noch bisher das Aufnahmegespräch beenden, okay?
Darf kann ich nicht so viel sagen, aber...
Also, es besteht der Verdacht auf Magenblutung oder vielleicht noch...
Woher kommt so etwas?
Ja, es kann so viele Ursachen sein.
Jetzt kann ich nicht so viel sagen, okay?
Jetzt brauche ich ein paar Untersuch von Ihnen.
Was kann man da gucken?
Wie kann man das feststellen?
Ja, ja, okay.
Als erstes würde ich Sie körpäl untersuchen, okay?
Danach plane ich eine Labontesun, deshalb wird ein Kollege bei Ihnen Blut abnehmen, okay?
Dann machen wir einige Bildgebändesverfahren.
Ich meine, ja, Ösofago Gasodiodinescopie.
Wie heißt das?
Ja, das klingt vielleicht ein bisschen kompliziert,
aber machen Sie sich keine Sorgen, das ist Routineverfahren, okay?
Das ist ein Magen-Spiegelung.
Ah, das habe ich schon mal gehört, ja.
Ja, ja, mit einer Kamera, also mit einer...
Und dann kann man gucken, ob das da blutet oder nicht?
Ja, also es gibt eine Schlau mit einer Kamera.
Dann wir führen diese Schlau, also durch ihren Mund,
in den Ösofagus, also Speisenröhre, dann bis zu...
gegebenenfalls Zifferfinger dann, okay?
Und bin ich da in der Kose?
Ja, vor der Untersuchung bekommen Sie nicht von der Kose, also Teilweise,
in der Kose, deshalb bringen Sie nicht mit, okay?
Okay.
Und deshalb machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich gesagt habe, das ist Routineverfahren.
Und wir betrachten ihr Gewäbe, dann, wenn es erfolgreich ist,
können wir ein Probe entnehmen, okay?
Dann wir schauen im Pathologie, in einem speziellen Laboratoren,
ob das gefährlich oder nicht, wie zum Beispiel.
Ja, der will ich einmal hoffen, dass das nichts gefährlicher ist.
Ja, ja, wenn es erfolgreich ist, können wir diese Flutung stillen
und dann mit einer Adrenalinlösung, okay?
Ja, das...
Ich klingt aber alles ganz schön kompliziert.
Muss ich dann jetzt stationär hier bleiben?
Ja, also das wäre besser.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe ein paar Tage, wäre besser, Sie bei uns zu bleiben, okay?
Okay.
Ich spreche mit meinen Obarst jetzt, komm mit Ihnen,
sprechen wir noch aus, fühle ich darauf, okay?
Ja, super, das ist gut.
Okay, okay, danke schön.
Okay, ja.
Ja, gibt es doch Fragen?
Ja, vielleicht können wir das auch fragen.
Sind Sie schwindelig und die Farbe,
ihre Stuhl verändert sich?
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Wenn ja, wann, wie oft?
Ja, schwindelig gefragt, aber ja, vergiss nicht, das wäre...
Ja, das ist das einzige, was mir aufgefallen ist.
Ja, normalerweise frage ich immer, Stuhlgarten und so weiter,
aber vergiss nicht, vielleicht wegen der...
Ja, okay, aber ist natürlich ein guter Hinweis
und ja, die hätte das ja auch selber sagen können,
die Anakowalski, hat sie aber nicht,
weil sie nicht gefragt worden ist.
Sie hat also nicht gesagt,
dass sie so ganz dunklen Stuhlgang hat,
das hat sie nicht verraten.
Aber der Doktor hat sich ja nicht gefragt.
Ja, ja, wie ich gesagt habe, normalerweise frage ich immer,
wegen dem Missing.
Auf die Frage wäre das gekommen, ja.
Ja, aber sie haben keine...
Doch.
Doch, sie hat dunklen Stuhlgang.
Okay.
Aber erst kürzlich, ne?
Erst?
Seit wenigen Tagen.
Okay.
Wie viel mal haben Sie bemerkt, dunkle Stuhlgang?
3 Mal.
3 Mal, okay.
Ja, das ist eine wichtige Frage, okay.
Gut, hat sonst noch jemanden Tipp oder eine Frage?
Ähnlich, ja, ich habe ja schon...
Das hat er tatsächlich gefragt.
Ja, das hat er ganz klar gefragt, ja.
Hatte sie aber nicht vorher.
Sie sagen, Bescheid, wenn sie zum Arztgespräch fertig sind, ne?
Ja, wir können machen.
Können wir schon?
Okay, ich kann anfangen, oder?
Ja, gerne, ja.
Okay, passt.
Ja, guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute gerne diese 7-6-Jährige-Patientin
Frau Kwaski vorstellen.
Frau Kwaski ist am 9.07.1954 geboren.
Sie ist 79 groß und 1,68 Meter groß.
Also 79 kg schwer.
79 kg schwer und...
Groß, ja, okay.
Ja, Frau Kwaski stellte sich heute wegen seit ein paar Tagen
bestehende starke nicht australende Obabau-Schmerzen bei uns vor.
Die Schmerzen seien im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden.
Die Patientin bewertete die Schmerz-Interstate
auf eine Schmerz-Kolakone 1 bis 10.
Am Anfang mit 7.
Nach dem Essen 5 bis 6.
Und die Patientin klackte über eine Sivarimalige...
Hematomäsis.
Ja, und die Beschwerden seien von nausea,
die schwer, so wie seit ein paar Tagen bestehende,
Müdigkeit begleitet gewesen.
Die Patientin gab an, dass sie innerhalb von 4 Wochen
2 bis 3 kg zu genomen habe.
Wie erklärt ihr das?
Die Patientin hat eine Sivarimalige,
die schwer, so wie seit 4 Wochen,
2 bis 3 kg zu genomen,
aber sie ist sehr krass.
Die Patientin ist sehr krass,
aber die Patientin ist sehr krass,
weil sie wegen der Medikamenteneinnahme
einen Gewicht zu genomen haben.
Wegen der Medikamenteneinnahme?
Ja, wegen der Medikamenteneinnahme.
Und die weitere vegetative Annahme,
sei bis auf nächtliche Hypohydrose,
seit 14 Tagen,
so wie schmerzbedingte Apathosikkeit unauffällig.
Die Patientin, die Patientin,
die Patientin zufolge sei,
auch Melena, 2-mal, seit ein paar Tagen aufgefallen.
An Vollkrankungen seien seit über 10 Jahren
eine arterielle Petonie bekannt.
Mit 10 Jahren sei die Patientin wegen
einer rekt seitigen Kursband rüpto operiert worden.
Aktuell haben die Patientin keine Beschwerden.
Die Medikamenteneinahme gab die regelmäßige Einnahme
von Prätnisolon 15 mg morgens,
so wie Kaptopril 5-20 mg morgens und abends.
Zusätzlich nehme die Patientin,
die Doktor Fennack 50 mg 3-mal am Tag ein.
Die Allergien an Amnesien seien unbekannt.
Und in Besuch auf Gemus mit Tell rauche die Patientin
seit 20 Jahren 20 Sekaretten pro Tag.
Sie trinke ein Gleiswein,
sie gab es einmal pro Woche,
sie gab es ohne Drogen zu konsumieren.
Keine Drogen zu konsumieren?
Die Patientin sei eine Hausfrau,
sie hat zwei erwachsene Kinder.
In Besuch auf Femininahme sei ihr Vater
mit 79 Jahren an einem Yokat in Fartgeschworben.
Ihr Mutter sei mit 78 Jahren
an Altersbedingter Krankung verstorben.
Die Patientin habe zwei Geschwister,
sie gelten aktuell als Gesundes.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Aufgrund von bisherigen Anamnesenangaben,
ich habe eine sehr interessante Blutung
mit Ulkustin.
Aber als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen,
Magenkatnomen oder auch
Yokatinfarkt in Wetraht.
Als weiteres vorgehen,
ich frage,
als erstes würde ich die Patientin
Körperunterzungen untersuchen.
Bei Körperunterzungen palpiere ich
Abdomen.
Ich mache Inspektion,
ob bei der Patientin
Rebound oder Abwäschpanung ist.
Was machen Sie da?
Nach der Vitalparameterüberprüfung
und der Körperunterzungen,
ich plane eine Labodiagnostik,
inklusive kleines Blutbild,
auch Entzündungsparameter,
Herz, Neben, Leber,
auch Colostase-Werte.
Und woher gucken Sie noch besonders?
Im Kleines Blut können wir
niedrigte Hemoglobin-Werte erhauchen.
Das erwarten wir, ja.
Aber wenn wir jetzt mal ein bisschen weiter denken,
wie potenziell weiteres vorgehen ist,
dann sollten wir weiteres vorgehen.
Ich habe noch eine weitere Frage.
Was würde man da sinnvollerweise noch mitmachen?
Gerimmungsparameter.
Und die Blutgruppe?
Das muss man inkludieren.
Man muss das auch inkludieren.
Man muss inkludieren, dass man Kreuzblut hat.
Ja, richtig.
Wegen der höchsten Blutverloren
kann man Blut-Substition.
Wir brauchen deshalb ein Blutkreus
und Blutgruppe zu beurteilen.
Genau.
Und danach als Bilkewendesverfahren
würde ich Özerfabrogasodiodemyskopie
mit dieser Untersuchung
können wir die Blutung stillen
mit Adrenalinlösung oder mit Klempen.
Auch ich würde
Helikobacterpylori.
Ja, sehr gut.
Überprüfen, ja.
Wenn die Patientelkombakterpylori positiv ist,
würde ich eine Antibiotktherapie.
Ja, genau.
Anordnend, dass
Kleptomisien amoxicilien
gegebenenfalls metrenasol
und mit Pantoprazol.
Wenn es nicht
die Helikobacterpylori negativ ist,
ja, können ja mit Pantoprazol
gegebenenfalls
verabreichen.
Aber in erstlinie sollten wir
die Blutung stillen.
Genau.
Dann empfehle ich den Patienten empfehlen,
Ernährung umstellen,
fetthaltige
und sogarhaltige Ernährung
zu versichten, auch Sport zu machen.
Auf ihre alten Tage soll die sich noch umstellen.
Ja, richtig.
Das ist eigentlich,
alle Patienten mit über 50, 60 Jahren ist wichtig.
Aber in diesem Fall auch können wir besonders empfehlen.
Empfehlen, ja, das ist schon richtig.
Ansonsten, der Patient habe Überkeit.
Anausea.
Auch wir können auch ein Medikament,
das heißt,
Methyloparamide
verabreichen, wenn es erfolgreich ist.
Ansonsten, ja.
Haben wir doch schon ein schönes Programm.
Haben Sie doch schon gut geplant, was wir alles vorhaben?
Und haben doch auch für alle Eventualitäten
schon
das weitere Vorgehen wunderbar beschrieben.
Gut, dann,
untersuchen Sie mal die Patientin jetzt weiter.
Ich bin gespannt, was die ÖGD bringt.
Und dann halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufen,
denn da drüber.
Ja, was dabei rausgekommen ist.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja, wunderbar.
Hat doch jemand eine Frage dazu?
Ja, Doktor, gönn es.
Ich möchte ein Fügeln.
Eine Terapie.
Ist diese Fall, ich denke, eine Notfall-Situation?
Ja.
Und wir haben als nicht diese Situation
in der
Du hast dich verstanden, Zoltun.
Also, Zoltun, wir haben einen Ansatz.
Ja.
Ja, also ich glaube, das ist jetzt wieder so ein bisschen das Problem dieser theoretischen Sprachprüfung, ja.
Dass man natürlich eigentlich so eine Patientin nicht episch breit befragt,
sondern dass man eigentlich schon mal erstmal was macht, ja.
Und die praktisch ans Monitoring hängt und dass man der als erstes mal vielleicht schon mal zwei Zugänge legt.
Ja.
Aber das ist natürlich in dieser, gerade auch in dieser Zoom-Situation, ein bisschen sehr schwierig.
Aber natürlich wäre das irgendwie schon angezeigt, klar.
Aber die hat ja noch keine Zeichen davon gehabt, dass sie jetzt jeden Moment vom Stuhl fällt.
Ja.
Mag das vielleicht gerade auch so gehen?
Auch in diesem Fall kann man eine Choroskopie denken, also aber ja nicht vielleicht am Anfang,
vielleicht danach, das ist älter Patient, eine Nukle-Stuhl, ja, vielleicht.
Ja, aber ja eigentlich nur, wenn das obere ausfällt, wenn die oben keine Blutung hat im Magen,
dann könnte man weiter gucken sozusagen.
Aber wenn es tatsächlich bei der oberen Blutung, wenn die sich bestätigt, ja.
Ja, es braucht man nicht.
Und vielleicht wäre es auch am Anfang bei der Anomese-Gespräch zu den Prüfer sagen, ja, das ist ein Notfall.
Ich würde gerne in ein, also soll ich die Notfall-St situation ergreifen und so weiter, wäre besser.
Das ist glaube ich das, was Dr. Günndes gerade gemeint hat, ne?
Ja.
Dass man praktisch, wenn man hört, was die Patientin beschreibt, dass man sagt, oh, hallo, Freunde,
jetzt müssen wir die erst mal anschließen und eine Infusion reinhängen und was, was ich zumindest mal nach dem HB gucken,
damit die jetzt nicht gleich hier vom Stuhl fällt, ne?
Ja, das ist sicherlich ein sehr guter Hinweis, ja.